are we on
yep all right awesome hello hi how are
you
doing well good to be here with you
yes do you want to introduce us do I
want to introduce us yeah I believe
you're all worried and I'm Jorgen great
yes Jurgen is a very interesting man
fascinating man if you want to find out
more about him in his books and things
check out his interview with Alan but
now I'm here with him to explore we're
here to explore and be spontaneous and
co-creative so what do you think about
that sounds cool cool with it all right
so you've been around the block about
life I think that's true all right
well then thanks for giving me
eat our heart
yeah being with you I feel inspired to
perform it's a word you use yeah I feel
like I want to show up hmm make yourself
present as it were but what about our
viewers what do they want
I don't know I hope they find something
useful and what we are doing here what
I've said earlier that there was
something in there that was inspiring
or maybe disturbing or maybe jarring all
of that would be good but what if our
pace isn't perfect
I don't know what a perfect pace is in
terms of what we are creating here I
have no measure
[Music]
you think what you were asking and what
I'm quite willing to do is make
ourselves present to each other yes
how is it for you the pacing what if
it's not perfect
I just feel sensitive to it all like I
don't want to just let anyone down or
something
[Music]
yeah
I'm not sure how you could let me down
well when you share I get more meanings
than just the words because you're
filled with energies and so I'm
listening so what are the energies that
fill you up
like with you there is I like an
instructor and that's a big one the
instructor and like a challenger
and a
like
there's a sense of like we're the same
like do you realize
things like that
yeah that makes me feel seen
[Music]
uh-huh
you know
we have had
[Music]
comments that slowing down can be hard
to watch and
that's present with me now
what do you have anything to share
around that I think there are many
places where it's difficult to slow down
look when you're talking about the
instructor you know being with students
it's very much like a certain fairly
rapid speed although at times I go too
fast but I think it's really important
to slow down I think it's really
important to have silences to listen and
open up the space for new questions and
new answers
so you're gonna be doing all the
teaching here here yeah
I'm not sure what you mean doing all the
teaching here what is the here that
you're referring to here in our hangout
oh session
I don't know had planned on teaching
yeah
is that what you want me to do I mean
you've got two books we're looking at
right now do I have anything to teach
you of course
I assume I mean there are so many people
everybody can learn from so why wouldn't
you have anything to teach me I don't
know you saw I don't know I don't have a
sense of what that all could be
if I ended up teaching you
I mean you've built a whole reputation
you have a place in the world and in
people's hearts so would you be ok with
that
sure all right what about you Alan
yeah great you've been over it for a
while you know you've already done the
interview with Alan and connected with
us before that and so now it's getting
dark and you and Jillian and you're
still here
as am I
what's your experience like right now
I am waiting by fault
because we've never really talked much
together
and you said
would it be okay if you were teaching me
something so I was kind of just waiting
great you're into consciousness
it's one of the topics yes
I have some gifts around that area
and perspectives
in capacities
Allen propped me up here on the camera
as he's been doing a lot recently
so do I have something to show I need to
show the viewers in perform is what's on
my mind I was wondering whether you had
any responses to what I talked to Ellen
about
hmm
from your perspective of consciousness
practices gifts and capacities
well
one thing that was present for me around
that was like that maybe I could
be in Alan's seat
and maybe I should
that came up
like you should do
more of the interviews
questioning
would you have asked different questions
well I like a lot of Alan's questioning
and recognize his development there but
with a lot of the crystallized flowers
of humans that join us on the show there
is a sense of connection I feel in a
receptivity and dynamic there that I'm
not sure Allen has
[Music]
so you're talking about a receptivity or
sensibility that goes beyond words is
that what you're talking about
kind of
how would you say
I feel
intimate
with
people
so intimate with what they're sharing
[Music]
like for moments that all
become it you really enter their worlds
yeah
yeah yes
I hold space with their worlds I hold
their worlds I complement their worlds
and I interact with their worlds
[Music]
what a conversation to be having
what do you mean you mean this
conversation or the previous
conversation
well we're talking about me wanting to
replace Allen in certain ways and he's
sitting right there and and we just got
a comment from Angela 22 that says yes
he doesn't listen and talks too much of
his own thoughts rather than listening
to what his guests say Thank You Angela
for the comment
thanks Alan yeah
I'll let you know if other people
comment ok let us know your thoughts
everyone
so you think you might want to
be more receptive listen more
[Music]
I
would like that ability to land further
to have more traction in what we're
doing so like when we did the interview
earlier anteater
enter that world and you held that world
of that conversation right are there
things that you either observed or that
you would have liked to ask or that
puzzle - well one thing I noticed was
that your energies the ones that can
impact the environment the ones you can
use but you're intentional energy it
felt like was
in combination with mine enacting this
movement creating this movement
facilitating this movement I'm
describing
so there was a synergy there for you
yeah or will you just clarify for a big
red gee asked if you're high AF
and hi a
but I have developed myself in such a
way that
the things blocking that natural
you can look at that camera yeah there
you go while you talk into the mic yep
the things that could block that sort of
state that
maybe are not in the way right now
that willingness to be here
not need to rush
I'm interested to know if Angela big red
other viewers Jurgen you Ori other
guests that we've had on the show I'm
interested to know given the the time
that we have to be with the guests that
we have on the program and the amount of
beauty that their spirit has to unpack
on the program how I help them unpack
that beauty in their spirit and how you
unpack help unpack that beauty in their
spirit and the similarities differences
efficiencies that type of stuff
I'm curious if you could share your
experience around that
in terms of ways Alan
connects with people versus me
well Alan you know connects through well
the preparation and the questions and he
is very empathic and picking up on
themes that speakers say in the
conversation I think your presence is
different because you're very receptive
and very quiet and like part of what
would I'm wondering is what your your
questions are or
your desires are to know or to be or
what what is important for you in this
that's more obscure for me with with
Alan that's all verbalized with you it's
more
you're here
waiting for things to unfold it seems
[Music]
yes
[Music]
yes
feel I feel a disposition to be
responsive to the people around me
otherwise I can be uncentered in my
expression however I also have knowledge
and things to teach
and much more perhaps interesting
expression it just hasn't arisen much
yet
do you see any way that can help you
make it arise
conversations and maneuvering like these
feel like they set a foundation for me
to operate more easily and authentically
but it seems that that knowledge that
you hold on the inside is difficult at
this moment to put towards
[Music]
yeah I feel
I feel a little bit like I'm surrendered
to this timing in this unfoldment of
sorts is there anything at this moment
inside that you can grab and bring out
[Music]
what do you mean
you're talking about the unfolding that
there is something unfolding from the
inside and I was wondering whether there
is something that you can get a hold of
at this moment in
whatever put an image or word or
sentence to it yeah and just before that
we have just a couple more comments okay
yeah just a thank you from big red for
streaming and producing content and we
said you're so welcome we love doing it
thanks for engaging with their channel
we got a nice little heart back then
another comment from big red and then
Angela big red said watching ory
reminds me of someone on xanax a very
slow and relaxed and then Angela said
original interviewer was great just a
little excited is all hi Angela I'm Alan
good to meet you thanks for commenting I
didn't mean any offense just an
observation I just wanted the guests not
to break his flow so much you are all a
delight yeah thanks Angela I appreciate
that comment I've actually gotten that
before like yeah
[Music]
maybe we should that if you could Alan
we're just silencing my phone here
got it thanks dude that's an interesting
observation
because I noticed that you for example
were really flowing today in the
interview
I mean you reached a richness of
expression that was precious and if I
were in the interviewers seat with you I
would have held that with devotion I
would have held it with care I would
have featured it as much as possible
I appreciate what you're saying them
great
I do too
the guests below States in more devotion
featuring them in their devotion more
so
there's something here does the capacity
here in this vessel within me where that
could be effective
useful
for being with guests
and
I
and alive about its landing
so are you saying that you want to see
more of devotion appreciation in these
interviews and that's a contribution
that you would like to make
even more essentially I would like to
see more of me in the interviews
want them to be my interviews
that stops you
good question
old momentum Oh momentum as though it I
said yeah
I'm not sure what that means
well right now you could say that
simulation is still Allen's show he
created it and he does a lot of the work
involved so that's the old momentum
there's not a lot I want to take away
from that
but I would like it to be my show
energetically
[Music]
to be able to hold space for the project
fully
without distortion
do you have any thoughts about how you
might get there
Angela commented about your honest
that's what she said thanks for
commenting you though thank you
right now no just an impulse a movement
that's happening within me and around me
is there any way that you see Alan
helping you in that with supporting that
movement
not anymore
it feels like a bigger movement than
Alan
Allen had the vision to bring me on
board at a pivotal time in both of our
paths
but now
this shift I'm sharing feels bigger than
him
[Music]
where would you want to put your energy
a couple quick comments Marcos Luna
thinks for commenting you've watched our
show quite a bit uncommon said we really
appreciate you chiming in he says I love
what you guys are doing I agree it's a
new wave that we are riding that's right
yes
what is the way
Marcus
or
you're in there Alan what is the new way
or maybe we can address also year
against question I thought was
interesting to me what where would you
want to put that energy that you feel is
emerging mmm in everyone's hearts so
Allen can do interviews and everything
he's doing but I want to be in his heart
I want to be in the heart of the project
totally
so
where is the energy I want where do I
want my energy to go into this everyone
I don't need to be in people's throats
but I want to be everywhere another
quick couple comments Marco's Luna
responded saying the wave is a new way
of living a new way of being in the
world and an Melissa elephantine who's
also a frequent viewer and commenter
thanks for commenting Melissa shout out
to you she says I loved Horry cuz he can
hold huge energies I love Alan because
he makes it fun to see where and how
that huge energy lands and gets used
thanks for commenting Melissa thank you
interesting
like Orie being at the edge of seeing
the wave and then me maybe seeing on how
it's gonna impact the existing
socio-economic fabric interesting also
Marcus just said I love dr. Kramer thank
you
I 500 Melissa if you could maybe write a
little bit more about that that'd be
interesting yeah thank you for your
comment what do you guys think about
what Melissa said it didn't
like it completely encapsulates what I'm
sharing here
I also agree with what she's saying but
don't feel satisfied by it
sounds like the center of what you want
to share is really that heart energy
that you want to put out put into the
project to support Alan to support
everything that's happening here to
support interviews interviewers and that
that you feel very strongly about that
heart energy and sharing that and
energizing the project in that way yes
yes that's right thank you
energizing the project with the heart
energy
exactly
Melissa commented again and said with
huge energies higher consciousness broad
perspectives even beyond words but we
still have to use it that's the
integration piece maybe that means that
the words are still needing to be used
to help us integrate into the next
higher consciousness what I see
happening is that we're trying to put
something to words and then we go into
that space that is beyond words that is
energy which we can't label easily and
part of the challenge is to
go back and forth because if we don't
put words to it we may miss out on
something but if we don't connect then
there is not the depth at the heart
connection yes Markos says I'd love to
hear what brought dr. Kramer onto the
program that's one thing that interests
me about all your guests and just before
dr. Kramer answers Marcos we have at the
end of every single interview we collect
a testimonial from the guests about why
they think people should care about
watching the program and so will
eventually be stitching that into some
sort of a compilation and we'll be
releasing that but if you'd like us to
ask the guests on the program maybe
towards the end that question that could
be an interesting question to ask and we
appreciate you mentioning that thanks
Alan what I'm excited about is that
simulation is a profound project
and it's in the heart of the Silicon
Valley and in the world in many respects
it's positioning is very special
and I want this project is this project
to be I want it to be
of a high caliber
I wanted to be a soulful expression
this grounded in the world artifact that
is simulation interviews with high-tech
camera equipment and business
entrepreneur professionals and economics
leaders and all the other fields
virtually I want it to be enveloped with
this this energy of love with this
high-caliber crystallized spiritual
integrated energy
so yeah it's a wonderful intention great
yeah yes an endeavour worth pursuing
mm-hmm absolutely
well everything that I've experienced
here and everything that I've seen
certainly has been high-caliber and I
appreciate from both of you
yeah actually the you know the attention
and the warmth and the hard energy that
is here so for me that's very apparent
and it's something that I feel great
thank you thanks jörgen think sorry yeah
I feel that too what you're describing
about your role with what is going on
and how to have that occur optimally is
something that I'm open to figuring out
for sure yeah
I don't yet know if you may be doing
these separately for now is probably
good and see where it leads
there's definitely something about
getting into unpacking the spirit of the
guests on the program that I just want
to make sure does not get lost in that
process and also that well unpacking the
spirit of the guests I think I can do a
good job at unpacking everything else
perhaps is your role like expedite gift
ok I see some overlap with those of
course there are of course things that
you know we haven't done you know we
haven't
engaged in any practice that would get
us into a different state of attention
for example right because we've I mean
our silences maybe the closest we got to
that right but other than that we've
been talking right II you know but we
have not used any other ways of making
ourselves present to each other
mmm interesting Ori has led that on the
program before he's led us into those
types of experiences together that is a
non talking or very little talking many
times eyes are closed occasionally they
open
well it was also thinking that different
guests I'm sure have different things to
offer in that regard
you know there's what you do and they're
the guests bring yeah yeah
yes
I think that sounds true so thank you
for sharing absolutely yeah
thank you
Melissa says that that we both are fully
capable of pulling off the new world
alright let's go for it
cool
it's also thing also Jurgen will you
answer that question for Marcos just
what brought you onto the program well
ah who brought me up to the program well
two things really you know he's the one
who wove the connection so that was
wonderful but then also bio a coma
laughs a for those guys here a couple
episodes ago yep yeah and but then
seeing you in action and seeing you know
the conversational quality and I really
appreciated that because you know the
their interviews which have their own
function and usefulness but I'm really
interested in conversations which are
generative and and that's you know I
think where were you're headed and what
you're doing
and what's important to you so and I
think that's where you get into depth
and deeper exploration so I I saw that
and that made me feel like yeah quite
interested in doing that that's exciting
and for me that's exciting because it's
not every day that you have that level
of conversation and I think you know the
more of these conversations we can have
the better and they're precious
yeah thank you thank you
they thank you you're gonna Marco says
nice I agree he also asks him maybe this
is a good question for you both is there
anything that the average person can do
to align themselves with this same
pursuit that question in itself feels
like it's coming from the right place
yeah
being with questions like that to me are
the answer asking that question is
important and listen to the answers in
your dreams and your meditations and
being outside
but keep asking the question yeah great
yeah I like that too something that's
interesting for me that's arising is
just figuring out what the energetic
dance and dynamics are that creation is
gonna be continuing to channel through
or E&I through this project in order for
it to manifest its gifts into the world
and what that exactly is going to look
like
[Music]
having
a good amount of Venn diagram overlap
with the way that we feel and experience
and care but also Ori
knowing
outside of my circle and then me knowing
outside of Orie Circle and what those
unique areas that don't overlap so much
are the also interesting gifts that will
be brought forth and something that's
happening right now is figuring out what
to do about the dynamics of the guests
coming onto the program because given
the current state of the attention
economy and transitioning the attention
economy into what is the new world where
it has maybe more space for the slower
in a pace one second and just check in
with you and ask if this feels
compelling
yeah I mean this makes the sense to me
hey I mean if I hear you correctly you
know you're really well you were just
talking about attention and I
immediately had a comment that I'm glad
we talked for however long we talked
which was very long which is very aware
that people actually you know anything
that gets published have that long space
to talk which really also shifts the
energy that there's a time for
exploration and you know paying
attention to each other and
I don't know if there is anything more
that you need because part of it is
there's a very open space I mean you
have you know you prepare the interview
you have questions and you know and all
of that but there's a lot of openness in
terms of what emerges and the
conversation and I think that's really
where the gifts are yeah look agreed so
I don't know if that's a response but
this yeah
letting the conversation go on all those
different paths is a lot of where the
gifts are I completely agree yeah I
don't know if you should you know set a
more structured format of any kind I
think I'm not sure that that would
actually work you know and I think
different interviewees are gonna be
different
yeah and to clarify on that last part
that was that was coming out which I
thought was also gonna be really
interesting Angela just comments you
guys are so open and honest and raw it's
beautiful
it's a really nice thing to hear Jolla
yeah thank you and just to follow up so
it's just that the world that we're
currently embedded in has the attention
economy at full blast and that we aim to
help unleash the guests at their best on
the program and what they've done in
their lives and what new codes they're
bringing to the world is a compression
that is facilitated by the interviewer
and so the interviewer being very
skilled in that exact ability and domain
is extremely important and
doing this over the last four years with
over a thousand people has been
something that I'm become deeply
passionate about and Ori has helped me
with that
HAARP energy that he's talking about
that has helped me become a better
interviewer and more skillful
spiritually as well and the new world
will I think have more space for the
slower pace that Ori brings and as you
said on the show year again you said
whatever works and that's been something
that has been said by our guests before
as well right hand path left hand path
whatever works and get your way back up
to communing with the divine with source
with creation and so in this case it is
both whatever works and it's also that
the new world will potentially have more
space held for this in the attention
economy yet what the existing social
fabric is and how they engage with this
it is different in terms of what's
outside that Venn diagram and what Ori
would bring with his what's outside his
ven died in his Venn diagram that I
don't have and what's in my Venn diagram
that already doesn't have that I bring
as well this is very interesting
exploration of interviewer potentials I
currently like the format that we're
going with where the guest comes on the
program and sits down for an interview
with me and then
the there's space held with Ori
afterward and there's more explorations
that happen and we can see how that
plays out over time and what ends up
happening well how do you feel about
that to be continued
these talks have been happening they've
been showing up and I hear you guys in
what your share in putting and so all
for the highest calling and to get ego
out of the way for the highest calling
yeah the thing is well do you have
something that you wanted to share
no I think you know I mean like we could
try to talk all night and continue but
no I think I think you know getting
eagle out of the way as you know it's
important and it's an interesting
challenge you know when you go beyond
that trap that you know to connect with
whatever self higher self you know
this deeper sense and I think that's
really I think where the conversations
are really generative when that happens
cool yeah thank you I think you do you
have anything on that
or you
I like what's forming
yeah me too
yeah thank you both
yeah carry on carry on carry on my
wayward son there'll be peace when you
lay your weary head to Valley or bump
boom boom yeah you guys let us know your
thoughts in the comments below everyone
we'd love to hear from you oh wow
another question from Markos just
kidding I have a question that I've
struggled with for a while how can we
hear or see the signs that the world is
showing us it's undeniable that life is
a dynamic conversation or dance with the
world how can we here recognize the
messages of the higher self
I'm always split between decisions and
I'm not sure how to recognize what the
world is saying thank you guys for
everything any thoughts on that as we
wrap
any thoughts
patience silence listening paying
attention to dreams listening to the
wind
all these things help it's not easy it's
not easy
thanks Horry thoughts on that yeah I
think that last comment you read out I
agree with it I think that there is
something real and
something real about this movement
talkative Mike there's something real
about this movement and that we're
discussing to be continued to be
continued she says thank you guys for
everything and that resonates with me so
beautiful you're getting already thank
you let us know your thoughts in the
comments below everyone Tori do you want
to close it or do you want me to do it
you can do it let us know your thoughts
in the comments below everyone would
love to hear your thoughts have more
conversations with your friends family
co-workers people online about the
subjects that we discussed in this
episode let us know what you're thinking
let other people know what you're
thinking support your again you can find
as links below you can support Ori his
links are below as well you can support
simulation all of our links are below as
well and support those artists those
entrepreneurs those leaders spiritual
there's in your communities that you
believe in support them help them grow
and build the future everyone manifest
your dreams into the world you love you
very much thank you for tuning in and we
will see you soon bye everyone
[Music]